unspoken rules in a no rules fight for
instance if you see a street fight first
off the opponents are always going to be
usually males of a similar size and a
similar age and a similar competence the
reason that you have a fight is in order
to determine who is the most physically
dominant between two people where the
answer isn't already obvious what that
means is that we need to play by the
same rules because if you play by a set
of rules that's different to mine that
makes the outcome of the contest
neutralize it it's no longer a reliable
sense of whether or not one is tougher
than the other eye gouging grind shots
biting usually kicking when someone's on
the floor all of this even in a no rules
street fight would usually be frowned
upon and especially if someone was to
pull a weapon out and the fascinating
thing is this gets reflected in movies
even written into movies think about the
bond Supremacy we have this inherent
understanding that there are rules that
people are supposed to follow and that
when someone breaks them that kind of
opens up another level and almost always
the guy falls out of a window after
Jason like hits him with